for an exclusive interview is the one
and only Carter Paige Carter it's good
to see you after that first of all your
I'm gonna play if you don't mind before
we get into your filing what was said
about you last night
in this interview actually it's it's the
it's the fullscreen put it up so we can
we can read it so Stephanopoulos said
you also had had your eye on Carter page
who had also been working with the Trump
campaign Comey says correct the
Stephanopoulos says and what was your
concern there and then he said Comey
says well similarly trying to figure out
is he in any way coordinating with the
Russians as part of their effort to
influence our our election well we hear
the word collusion all the time
collusion is not a word that's familiar
to me from my work and call me continues
and says the question is is anybody
conspiring or aiding and abetting
helping the Russians accomplish their
goal of interfering in the American
election that's what the counter telogen
Sinn vestigation was all about Carter
your reaction to that well I actually
love that quote about I forget it was a
very long series of words there but
conspiring or aiding and abetting and
that is a perfect description of what
the steel dossier was doing for on
behalf of the DNC and the Democratic
candidate that year so I mean it's it's
actually a perfect you know what he
various people we're doing in Washington
and again it's early we don't know the
full details but you know that's
basically sums it all up so Carter what
happened in federal court today what is
your what is your filing attempting to
show and what do you claim it will prove
ultimately well Laura it actually you
know it's a request or sort of a a road
map for what I'm planning to put out
there in terms of my amended complaint I
filed a complaint last September and I
plan to do a updated complaint and it's
it's interesting because everything it
was an honor to speak after the the
three FBI of former FBI officials
you know everything they're saying about
the restoring the dignity and kind of
you know looking out for the dignity of
the FBI
you know they reflect the people I've
been used I've never I never met mr.
Comey and they were the type of
individuals that were just on before me
that really represent exactly what I'm
used to dealing with in terms of all of
my interaction both both of the FBI but
also you know CIA and other intelligence
services so you know I hope in order to
do that what they need to do is you know
in terms of the restoration of the
dignity of the FBI is to release those
you know all of the FISA warrant
applications to get all the all the
right info out there as to what actually
happened you know that were you
surprised Carter Carter we surprised at
all when Jim called me brushed off the
question about why he didn't inform the
president and his first meeting with the
president in Trump Tower to do that
national security brief he didn't reveal
that the dossier was funded by Hillary
and he kind of said well that wasn't
that wasn't part that wasn't my goal
that wasn't that wasn't it wasn't
necessary to affect my goal were you
surprised about that it's just so late
in with so many political motives and I
think that's just another example I
think part of that quote I forget the
exact terms he used but you know I'm not
sure whether I use the term steal - yeah
I wonder if you use the term dodgy
dossier because that's exactly what it
was and it may it's so beyond any common
sense and what's interesting over the
last 24 hours and last week or so as
this has sort of become the big news
item is I was always wondering how come
I never got any how come the FBI never
reached out to me after I've sent them a
letter in September 20 2016 offering to
talk to them you know these fake reports
that are out there which apparently got
used eventually in the FISA Court
everyone everyone Carter I don't mean to
interrupt but everyone should understand
that not only did you offer to speak to
them then you did speak I believe to
Congress in March of 20
17 you did speak to the DOJ in March of
2017 and then they continued to apply
for another FISA extension correct am i
stating that correctly yes sir you
already met with them basically any well
yeah it's it'll be interesting once once
all this ridiculousness ridiculousness
is completely out there all right or
during the most ridiculous of the four
and you know I used to think that the
original one
you know when what's the world after the
world premiere of the dodgy dossier came
out in each one gets worse than the net
Carter each one gets worse than the next
because in each successive application
for the FISA warrant they knew they'd
continue to emit a material fact and
thank you so much for joining us